so can you describe to me
polyamory what is it
what does it mean because it's like
different terms yeah you have a nice
blog post about it yeah I have a
personal definition of it which I
readily admit is not shared by a lot of
people but to me the definition of
polyamory is simply not forbidding your
partner from pursuing intimacy with
others yeah it doesn't mean that you
have to pursue it personally like two
people could be married and only have
had sex with each other for 20 years and
as long as they're like you know what if
you ever you want to go have sex with
somebody else you're welcome to do that
well the interesting thing you said is
that doesn't mean they have to do it
they just have the freedom to do it yeah
it's the freedom that matters to me
which is a
uh I mean it's called the the polyamory
post he has so many good blog posts
people should just go look at your uh
your read your writing because it's it's
really really strong and often backed by
data but also just to deeply honest look
at yourself and your understanding of
the world
it's night it's
yeah it's refreshing to be like with a
lot of stuff I disagree with but I feel
like if I disagree with it you'll be
very open to arguing and and kind of
thinking through it just there's just
the honesty that really is from the
whole thing anyway so uh yes I mean it
would be interesting to kind of explore
what polyamory like how it works what
are the different versions what is the
what does that freedom look like what is
it what does that freedom feel like
to be able to go see other people
depends on you like do you want to go
see other people maybe you do maybe you
don't usually for me I tend to be pretty
happy with like one or a few people and
then occasionally I like some novelty so
usually I'll go like like I host orgy
sometimes so I'll host an orgy and then
I'll go have sex with people with the
orgy and then that'll be good for the
novelty for a while ask about orgies
yeah so how many people are in orgy
what's like a standard we're having a
Sunday picnic and Synology what's like a
number of people on it at an orgy oh
I've been I've only recently started
hosting orgies but I have been to a lot
of orgies and I would say like the
median is maybe 15 people I like how you
say median versus mean okay median is 15
people what's the dis what's the gender
distribution usually uh usually about
even it's like ideal if you can get more
women than men in most of them I've
recently been hosting free use orgies or
or juice or consent is assumed by
default when you enter and of course you
can revoke it anytime or go over a whole
bunch of rules to make sure it's very
safe you like have wristbands so
nobody's actually doing anything they
don't want to but uh and in those ones
you have to have more men than women I
thought free use was like
consensual like at any time
but it's at any time within the
constraints of this building or
something like that yeah so at the
orgies it's like you buy entering if you
wear a wristband uh then you are like by
default opting into consent so people
don't have to like do a thing where they
negotiate with you and like to be like
is this okay it's just the default is
like you just go for it and if they want
you to stop they say the safer like red
don't and then you have to stop
um and we do like exercise in the
beginning people saying red to make sure
that everybody knows exactly what the
rules are what's your favorite safe word
red right when I first started doing
like weird kinky [__] I was like oh
let's make a safe word and we pick the
word foliage I was like that's goofy
right and then but then it eventually
came a time where I did actually in fact
want to say the safe word and I couldn't
I was like like in agony I was like
crying like I can't make myself say this
stupid word right now
foliage so after that it's like red
doesn't matter I don't care it's not
funny we're just going with very simple
very practical how does an orgy compare
sexually uh to like a one-on-one sexual
experience
um like what is the same ballpark or is
it fundamentally different
I mean the experience of all both orgies
and one-on-one sex could be like really
high variety there's a high variety but
you kind of it's a little bit like
you're having sex with someone but
you're surrounded by really realistic VR
porn of other people having sex okay
cool and sometimes there's like three
sums also like maybe there's another
person involved but it's hard to like
have a whole bunch of people on one in
one cluster because usually there's kind
of different little clusters of people
having their experience sure I was part
of a 10 woman orgy it was a total
lesbian thing and that felt like a
writhing cluster it was very nice
but typically you kind of separate out
with like very small PODS of people
doing stuff okay so back to polyamory so
what uh what's a good uh What what does
it take to manage do you have a main
partner if you're being polyamorous and
you have you're dating multiple people
is there usually a main one for you
personally
uh for me personally it kind of yes like
right now I kind of two that aren't like
I see roughly around for me it's kind of
just descriptive like if I just happen
to be seeing you a lot more and I've
been confiding you more than you like
you're descriptively my primary partner
but I don't usually have rules to
protect that I'm down with rules to
protect it if you're like you're trying
to build something like if I buy a house
together I'd be like okay we need to
like whatever our relationship is we
have to do the thing we're both paying
the rent for the house or the mortgage
or whatever uh a lot of people do have
primary so it's very common to have like
X like prescriptive like I'm gonna get
married to you and you're not allowed to
like have anal sex with anybody else
that sort of thing what about like the
transparency and the communication they
have to do yeah you usually try to be
super honest extremely yeah I mean I've
learned over time that like even if it
seems like a very small thing you talk
about the small thing because often I
would just sort of have like a small
Twitch in myself like I don't know if I
like that but okay this is really minor
um it's probably nothing and I don't if
I talk about it's gonna make it into a
thing and I just don't want to make it
into a thing you know and I would I've
come to realize that it's worth making
into a thing because I can't predict it
time if like the small feeling I have is
going to grow and then when I grow it
now it's like much more difficult to
deal with
so now it's like any little bit of
jealousy I have immediately communicated
I'm like ah I'm a little jealous of you
right now I don't hold that in at all I
used to be kind of like back when I
first started being poly I used to try
to pretend that I was not a jealous
person and that backfired quite a lot
that's really interesting so you do
still feel jealousy oh yeah definitely
and like it and it's also interesting
that you kind of recommend when there's
a little bit of jealousy like to to to
bring that to the surface yeah just like
excessively communicate even if it feels
stupid like this is I feel like a cliche
I feel like a stupid therapist training
video like I just feel ridiculous
sometimes when I'm saying the things but
it's just it's I've learned over time
it's just important to just say the
things because like you know the
traditional view of jealousy is exactly
like you said if you bring it up to the
surface like it's gonna sound like
you're overreacting to everything
but you're saying like still do it
because you're you're basically your
brain blows stuff out of proportion
yeah and it's good to like
who's like dating this other girl and he
like really likes her and you like went
traveling with her and stuff and I was
like I feel jealous about it and I have
to tell him that and that way he can be
with me in it he like he like holds me
when I'm feeling jealous and it's like a
bonding experience you know but it's
important for me that like he's able to
handle it like I try not to date people
who really freak out when I have
negative emotions because I want to be
able to express that I'm upset by
something they're doing without it being
taken as a demand that they change their
behavior right he has to be able to
skillfully handle the interaction yes
yeah cool all right you're jealous like
I'm not gonna freak out about I'm not
gonna change my behavior I'm just gonna
be with you in that we're going to sit
in it together
I mean is some of that just insecurity
that you should also just Comfort like
basically alleviate your insecurity
bring it back to like a rational
objective evaluation right my
relationships I love it when people did
not reassure me I like not being
comforted quite a lot okay and so
usually the people I date don't I'm very
gravitating like it's one of the things
people do to make me fall in love with
them is if I say something really like
terrible and they're just like do not
give me any comfort whatsoever like
that's where my heart gets captured so I
typically am in relationships where I'm
like I mean I'm so jealous and they just
like do not reassure me at all and
that's good because it doesn't give me
an out like I have to deal with it
myself
that the other woman is better than me
like maybe that is an actual possible
reality which I don't want to be dealing
with my life in a way where I'm like
pretending like I'm only okay when that
reality is not true would you like them
to to uh say that that the other woman
is better than you yeah or that they if
they if they feel that yeah I mean they
should say it in according to themselves
like oh I prefer like I have a better
time with her than I have with you than
I would want to know that yeah and even
though even though that might be painful
to hear yes
that which can be destroyed by the truth
should be
ship what is that that your ego or
something like that my ego so your ego
just generally grows and you like the
destruction of it yeah
it's like a fun experience like I've had
like guys to be like well you're not as
pretty as I'd like I'm just like oh you
know so stabbed to the heart and but
then also they give me your number after
yeah
foreign